سر السعاده الزوجيه في كلمه علماء نفس
يكشفون عن كلمه السر لنجاح العلاقات
الزوجيه فما هي يا ترى
دراسه علميه شملت 40 الف حاله زواج على
مدار 50 عاما توصلت الى عامل مشترك بين كل
العلاقات الناجحه
العلماء قالوا بحسب ما نشره موقع شبكه سي
ام بي سي ان هناك عاملا مشتركا واحدا بين
جميع الازواج يتلخص في انهم يريدون ان
يكونوا موضع تقدير وان يتم الاعتراف
بجهودهم ومن ثم فان كلمه السر في نجاح
العلاقات الزوجيه هي كلمه شكرا الي ينبغي
ايجاد طول ملاحظتي ما يقوم به شركه الحياه
بشكل صحيح بمعنى التركيز على الايجابيات
وليس السلبيات
[موسيقى]
العلماء قالوا بان يقدم الازواج لبعضهم
بعض عبارات الشكر والتقدير لكل ما يفعلونه
بشكل روتيني حتى لو كان صغيرا خاصه اذا
كان شيئا بسيطا ويفعلونه كل يوم لكن لا
يقتصر الامر على مجرد قول شكرا وانما
يخبرني بعضهم البعض ان تصرف بسيطه للغايه
يمثل حلا مهما على سبيل المثال عند تقوم
الزوجه بعمل في الزنقه ولزوج في الصباح او
عندما يقوم الزوج بشراء احتياجات المنزل
[موسيقى]
المرء يقول شكرا طوال اليوم تقريبا دون
تفكير في زملائه او عمل التعبئه في السوبر
ماركت او للغريب الذي يمسك الباب لحين
يعبر او قائد سياره الذي ينتظر يسمح له
بعبور الطريق بامان ولكن في اهم علاقات
حياته يمكن ان ينسى مد اهميه قول شكرا
لشركه او شريك الحياه
[موسيقى]